hey can i run people over
oh yeah bam
apple just released the 2020 eighth
generation
ipad with the a12 processor and today
we'll be comparing it to the 7th gen
ipad which had the a10
now we love this ipad we recommended it
to a ton of people
but the biggest downside was the a10
processor specifically for gaming
that's why today we are gonna be doing a
gaming test
we're gonna be running pub g and not
only we're gonna compare both of these
and see
how far you can push the settings and
what kind of smoothness and performance
you get
i'm also gonna be throwing in the 2020
ipad pro
just for fun so we could see what kind
of extra performance you get in extra
settings that we can get out
with the top ipad now this is the
perfect time to test out pubg
because we just got the latest update
1.0 the biggest update ever
and that's why pubg mobile wanted to
sponsor this video
and they made some massive improvements
not only to graphics quality
but also the performance so on older
devices
especially lower to mid tier ones you
can get up to 35 better performance
more efficiency less lag and we are also
going to be testing that out and we're
going to start out with
the 2019 ipad here we are on the home
page and we have a whole new ui we have
different pages here
so it defaulted to high with high frame
rate
uh we'll stick with that at first and
then we'll kick it up a notch and see
what we can get from this 2019 with the
a10
now i'll be honest it's been a while
since i've played pubg and i mostly
played on computer
be nice to me in the comment section but
i will say that i'm surprised by
how good the graphics look just out of
the box
i need an ak is that an ak nope okay
that will work
wait he died
hello come on come on come on come on
yes i'm sorry i'm very sorry
oh no no no no come on
all right be quiet no
so at least i got one person there um i
have to say
that that was smoother than i expected
so let's go ahead and jump into the
graphics settings
let's go to hdr and i'm going to sit
ultra for frame rate we'll see what we
get
and then usually these games you do get
aliasing so let's enable anti-aliasing
all right so that looks better and it's
still pretty
smooth who knows maybe with these
updates you don't need to update
to a new ipad oh
come on usman come on usman what are you
doing there usman
save us
this is where i'm seeing choppiness you
guys notice that
it's definitely running at 30 or lower
frames per second the detail looks great
yeah i see a little bit of glitchiness
and lagging
right here so i'd say for the 2019 with
the a10 or even the older ones they have
the a10 as well
you probably want to turn off the ante a
leasing even though it looks really good
when you get that little spike of lag
like right there you guys saw that
that experience isn't great i need a gun
i need a gun i need a gun
okay i got a revolver oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
no i died because of the lag you guys
saw
oh very interesting lower graphic
settings
to improve game smoothness so they
noticed that the frames were dropping
there
now let's go ahead and get our 2020. and
here we go it looks like we're set the
same
as far as the default we know i could do
better but i also have this ultra hd
option
which we don't have on the 2019
with the a10 processor and now i have a
picture quality comparison setting here
smooth compared to ultra hd
so look at that that looks a lot better
uh but before i test the ultra hd
let's do the hdr i'm gonna set it to
ultra just like on the other ipad
so right out of the bat look how much
smoother this is looks like i'm getting
a consistent 60 fps
those of you out there that play a lot
of pub g let me know in the comment
section
how much of a difference this update
made for you guys there's a lot of other
things that were added and i'll leave a
video in the video description
box come on
come on come on give me a hecha give me
a
headshot
yeah boy i'll finish my for you my
friend
there we go no no no no no no suck that
dude
yep there you go
throughout shooting and running around i
have not noticed any issues all right so
now let's go ahead and go into the
settings
graphics i'm going to turn on the ultra
hd frame rate
ultra let's see how that does and here
we're going to choose we want water
reflections
or do you want anti-aliasing let's check
out the water reflections we had
anti-aliasing on
so that looks good still smooth even in
ultra hd
look at that let's check out the water
ah beautiful i'm gonna go switch it back
to anti-aliasing
water reflections are cool i'd rather
have it be a little smoother on the
edges there
all right yes svd
perfect
no no no don't don't do that to me
where are you dude right there
[Music]
take that dude there you go got him
ah i didn't see you
all right so i gotta say that i'm
impressed i don't know if it's just with
the 2020 ipad
or if it's with pub g um or probably
both
anti-aliasing on i'm set to the ultra
and it's playing back
perfectly smooth i was gonna test out
the ipad pro
uh i still will i guess let's just go
ahead and test it out anyways
but i don't really see a reason to be
playing with the ipad pro because this
is playing back
perfect and now for the king of tablets
we are an ultra hd ultra frame rate
switch anti-aliasing on the first thing
i notice is a sound
that's definitely a difference we have
the quad speakers
so i'm getting sound from both sides
which is definitely nice
yeah we're getting out of here now
there's a tank there what did you do
what happened
whoa we got
whoa
help me please no
if i get this guy
no way he must be a bot another thing
that
is really standing out to me right now
is how hot
the back of the ipad is right here in
the center and where my hands are
holding
is much hotter than the 2020 a12 ipad
now i know the graphics are way more
powerful
but we're playing at similar graphics
settings and actually played
with the regular ipad longer where are
the bad guys
come on whoa no no no no no no
got him as vadim likes to say
hey can i run people over
oh yeah
[Music]
bam i would not have heard him with the
other ipads
gotcha all right there's only eight more
people let's finish this off
no no no no don't do that to me don't do
that
yep there we go
not too bad hey
since we're using the ipad pro let's
check out the 90 frames per second
option we could still have anti-aliasing
on
and you could definitely tell the
difference in smoothness here
yep
nice one more
yep not bad as you'd expect it's super
smooth at 90 fps and with the ipad pro
it can handle it no problem so what is
our conclusion with this video well
first off
pubg is very well optimized it was good
before now it's even better
and i was not expecting that the 812
equipped 2020 8th gen ipad is going to
play back
just as well as the ipad pro we had
the ultra hd graphics that we were able
to download
with the highest frame rate and
anti-aliasing and i could not tell a
difference as far as performance
now the 2019 a10 equipped 7 gen and same
thing for the 6th
that did not have the ultra hd graphics
and
even in the lower end graphics it was
still stuttering and having a little bit
of
issues now out of the box it played back
perfectly fine
it's only when you top out the graphic
settings is where it starts to fall
behind
so the 2020 8th gen is definitely a step
up now maybe in the future we're gonna
get higher frame rates with the best
graphics on the ipad pro
say 90fps maybe even 120 the speakers
are also better but this thing is 800
much more expensive than 329 for this
ipad and now we're going to recommend
this one even more than we did last year
because of that new chipset so thank you
guys for watching
you guys can go download uh pub g the
newest version with all the updates
in your app store and let us know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below we'll leave some links to some
great deals on ipads in the video
description as well
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video